I've never met a conservative who calls
themself corporatist but I've been a lot
of corporatists on Capitol Hill who call
themselves conservative hi I'm Nicholas
B with reason TV and today I'm happy to
say we're talking with the one and only
Ralph Nader about his latest book
unstoppable the emerging left-right
alliance to dismantle the corporate
state Ralph thanks for talking to Reason
TV thank you you born in 1930 you are
one of 34 oh I'm sorry
born in 1934 my mistake yeah you are one
of the most influential public policy
advocates or social figures of the past
fifty sixty seven let's call it the
post-world War two ERA you've been on
Sesame Street Saturday Night Live the
Ali G show everything else your first
big book was unsafe at any speed in 1966
you followed that up with the native
report on the FTC which might have been
as influential in a lot of ways you've
created organizations like Public
Citizen as well as all the perks that
college students especially know about
in unstoppable you write about what you
call the emerging left-right alliance to
dismantle the corporate state talk about
corporatism how do you define it and why
are why do you see the left and the
right kind of coming together to say
enough already
well corporatism is is a worldview that
large corporations should manage our
political economy and they should
strategically plan it and things will
come out okay it's part of the overall
globalization which undermines local
state national sovereignty and which
pulls down the economies to the lowest
level what countries overseas what's the
role what's the kind of growth curve of
corporatism is this something that in a
lot of ways starts with the New Deal and
then kind of extends into the post-war
era of you know the government or the
state and corporations thinking I kept
we're gonna work together to stabilize
everything well that's one sort of an
emergency partnership but I think the
the marker was around 1979
when congressman Democrat from
California Tony Coelho persuaded the
Democrats they could raise a lot of
money from corporate sources just like
the Republicans and from then on you
could see the decline in public hearings
on the corporate missmiss feet
malfeasance you can see the decline of
enforcement of health and safety
standards doctrines like deferred
prosecution they never had to plead
guilty the corporations they cut deals
and you see the increase enormous
increase and packs in commercial PACs
political anger in committee and that's
the lobby the government rigged markets
right yeah and and and they're they're
given to both Democratic Republic rise
yeah I mean this do you see a strong
difference or a meaningful difference
overall between the Obama
administration's policies and george w
bush's or is a is a continuity or is it
rupture it's very much continuity
obviously on social services there are
differences Medicare for example
Medicaid Social Security however on the
power areas is there much of a
difference on militarization of foreign
policy between Bush and Obama is there
much of a difference between bailing out
Wall Street and perpetuating a corporate
welfare state which libertarians call
crony realism now is there much of a
difference in the money in politics well
maybe in the Supreme Court there is but
you you go up to Capitol Hill and
they're both dialing for dollars like
crazy what yeah what did you think when
in 2008 and they you know just a couple
weeks before the election it was amazing
to me when John McCain you know because
a lot of people on the left and a lot of
people on the kind of libertarian end to
the right will say you know there's
really not much difference and it was
amazing in 2008 when John McCain
suspended his campaign to come back and
vote for tarp which Obama also voted for
and it seemed a kind of signal moment or
you know flare on us that these guys are
effectively very very much alike they're
very much invested in the corporate
statement that's what corporatism is
Franklin Roosevelt in 1938 sent a
message to Congress to set up the
investigative Commission on concentrated
corporate power it's called the tea NEC
in the message he said
never government is controlled by
private economic power that's fascism
those were his exact words
and obviously World War two gave fascism
another dimension but the combination of
corporate and government power so that
government becomes basically a service
arrangement for corporations is what we
call a corporate government corporate
state and what you call crony capitalism
and that's where the convergence by
left-right should focus on ok and let's
get to a couple of cases of that but
here here is you know specific examples
would you grant though that in a in a
true free economy one that is you know
kind of predicated upon you know
individual buyers and sellers doing
things could a company legitimately
without using the state grow to a
massive size where it control 6070 or
more percent of a market or do you think
by definition any company that controls
a certain percentage of of a market
needs to be regulated or could have only
gotten that way because of regulation
well I think if they if they have a
monopoly patent for example on a drug
they're gonna have a hundred percent of
marking for you know almost 20 years the
other theme is they grow because they
get huge amounts of taxpayer funded
research and development so if you look
at the major emerging industries the
biotech industry the computer
semiconductor industry the lot of the
pharmaceutical industry the
containerization industry and the these
are industries that grew as a result of
free transmission of government research
and development with some percentage of
that though because I have
pharmaceutical companies I mean it
basically for example it you know
there's definitely some research that
gets done and state-funded universities
or through government grants but it's
costing pharmaceutical companies a
billion dollars in ten years to bring a
drug to market they're putting up
virtually all of that and and there's
risk involved
first of all most of the important drugs
have NIH research sponsored input in
fact three-quarters of the anti-cancer
drugs the drugs like tax all for example
very much and it's given to them
essentially free with no reasonable
price restraints so and are you saying
then if there's a if there's a certain
percentage of free money or government
supported research going into something
the government has the right to regulate
that or what
well cuz it's a right to get some
perceived return for the taxpayer and
there is no return okay so what about
living longer or well like that but but
that's a good benefit yeah they do it
but for example in tax aw in 2000 a
woman with ovarian cancer wrote me and
showed that she would have to pay
fourteen thousand dollars for six
treatments to bristol-myers Squibb well
right the bristol-myers Squibb got that
right through the clinical testing free
from nih so what should she have had to
pay or should she have not well i
believe that if the taxpayer pays for
the intellectual property for the assets
there should be reasonable price
provisions because by definition the
government is giving a monopoly to
bristol-myers so that we get and I don't
want to well move to a separate area but
does that mean actually why don't we get
rid of patents then or or what I mean
are you saying that nobody should pay
more than five thousand dollars a year
for any drug maximum or had it you know
because I think I think there's a
general sense of fairness that everybody
would agree with that you know you you
if the government funded something that
leads to something and and that's I
think a more difficult thing to
determine the you might but yeah you
know then there should be some return
but then the question is like well if
you know if bristol-myers Squibb is only
going to get five thousand dollars a
year from patients they're not going to
do it because it's not worth their time
well it is worth their time because they
need to spend any money drug intensity
so the Billy I don't yeah the monopoly
patent is antiquated for drugs okay they
should get a reward you know a monetary
reward for creating the drug okay but
the patent is this it's a pay or die
situation there's this Gilead science
which you've read a month they're
charging out a thousand dollars a pill
for six weeks five thousand dollars I
think about it I mean you know some
drugs
are worth it right if they're gonna save
your life if they're if they're the only
thing that might save your life you know
I mean we could agree that certain
things are worth paying a thousand bucks
if you run that through the economy you
know it's worth the pain million dollars
for an ambulance yeah okay since
government research helped make that
possible well let's talk about a place
of convergence because your book is
actually about I mean it's it's a map of
saying okay look people on the right and
people on the left across the political
spectrum and you know we're thoug g''l
to it and everything agree
you know nobody likes nobody except the
direct beneficiaries really like
corporate welfare crony capitalists
whatever you call it and you tell an
interesting story in the book about how
you help push air bags into being and
that it actually started not through a
government mandate but you went and
talked to the guy who purchased vehicles
for the federal yeah talk a little bit
about that process yes the government is
a big consumer it buys almost everything
we buy food energy transportation plus
missiles which we buy let's be clear
though the government buys a lot more
prostitutes than I think either you or I
and and the agencies called the General
Services Administration so I learned
that the agency buys about 45,000
vehicles a year for government employees
to do their business and I went down and
lo and behold this man was a libertarian
right-wing supporter of Reagan a former
auto parts dealer in New Hampshire right
and he's like the government shouldn't
really be buying much of anything and it
should get the best deal that it can
that's right yeah save the taxpayer save
the lives and it worked
yeah and he put out of bed and GM knew
what was coming
so they accosted him at a social meeting
a gathering and said you shouldn't do
this mr. Cartman he said well you know
the customer's always right
right now so Ford bid and on 5,000 Ford
tempos to put airbags and the rest is
history so but here's I guess a question
because I found I find that story and a
lot of the stories at the book just
fascinating because there is and I know
you've worked with people like Grover
Norquist's of Americans
tax reform you know so they're there and
you know we see this all the time where
especially on things like military
spending and national surveillance civil
liberties huge convergence but doing the
right and the left in a way that's
genuinely different than 25 years ago
but then at some point why if if airbags
make sense why should they be forced on
to the auto industry as opposed to
wooden consumers say you know no but
nobody had to make VCRs mandatory or
remote controls for VCRs mandatory the
market drove that wouldn't it isn't it
enough of a demonstration project to say
hey here's a way you can save federal
employees lives and overall money and
why wouldn't that have worked in the
general population well it ended up
working it was a mandatory standard for
airbags as a result of the success of
but I'm saying why make the standards
okay because we're gonna save lives
police power
I mean why have you at least in towns to
save you budget but I by the same token
you didn't I mean there was not a recall
of all you know cars that didn't have
airbags at the same time so we've
recognized this is going to be phased
and what's wrong with allowing more of a
voluntary opt-in rather than mandating a
you know what perceived this is the one
best way let's mandate it for everyone
because it saves lives I mean it's like
fire prevention codes you know it's like
having brakes standards it's like having
no and I get all of that but but we
understand that there's always going to
be a phase in because we don't actually
say okay when we have fire standards we
don't tear down all the old buildings
that you can rely on the auto companies
to coercive phase and we'll talk more
about the auto companies which are near
and dear to your heart you are still you
do not own a car no okay and is that
because of the auto companies or nobody
will sell you one or no actually five
letter card they would advertise that's
true oh so that's a different process
okay well you know one of the things you
in in the book and and to go back to
this question of convergence which I
think a lot of libertarians would be
very interested in and you've been
working with yes you know various groups
on things is that you revisit the
agrarians of the 1920s and 30s
you know these are people on the old
right you have some kind words about
ludwig von mises in the book and say
that he's often misrepresented by what
you would consider corporate as well as
yeah yeah hey and even people like Marx
I mean you know it's clear that they're
contemporary people who invoke them off
and distort them to their own purposes
talk a little bit about what you find
powerful about the agrarians in
particular because you spend a lot of
time talking about people like Allen
Tate and a few others yes well they were
reporters poets farmers people who would
call themselves conservatives right and
they had a very sophisticated philosophy
of power first of all they believed in
the first principle of capitalism which
is defied by Wall Street which is if you
own property you should have some
reasonable control over it okay
whereas investors today owned the
corporations but they have very little
control over the bosses and their pay
and so what they argued was that the
only way you could have a democratic
society is if you decentralize property
ownership in those days they talked
about land because of small farmers that
were being overtaken by the large farms
but they also talked about shares and
they said look if we have shares and
companies we want to control it and we
should have decentralization of shares
as well the amazing thing about it is
they defied the Marxists and the new
dealers they felt the new dealers were
ready to be taken over by the big
corporations and the corporate state
which is what they feared right you
would agree that that effectively
happened oh yeah in the post worry or
you know it's you know a teen teen
what's good for General Motors is good
for the US and you're remarkably
pressing yeah that's why it's such a
fresh of chapter in the book because
people say I had no idea you know right
people actually did now do you worry at
all you know because I look back and
there's a guy who was kind of an
agrarian but talked in the 40s and 50s
and 60s Arthur ecourage of political
scientists who talked a lot about
decentralized in power that that's the
basic principle of liberal you know
classical liberalism but you know that
the agrarians were also they were very
anti-capitalist
in the sense they were you know they
tended to come from the south most of
them were overt racist people like Allen
Tate was you know a racial supremacist
in a way that's extremely you know it's
not even conscionable today but is there
a problem that they wanted to keep
things decentralized in a way to
preserve their status quo at the cost of
you know maybe you know our ancestors
people who were streaming over from the
Middle East or from southern Italy or
southern Europe into cities because
that's where cities were you know cities
and capitalism were the place where
people had more opportunities I mean do
you worry about that yeah there's
probably something there's something
that they didn't mention African
Americans except sharecroppers I thought
that was an atrocity right but they
definitely they didn't want their sister
to marry well either yeah that's those
times right and they didn't mention
women except in the book right there's a
woman who taught at Vassar we just
ripped the hell out of the men and went
after the suffrage is saying you freed
us and then you didn't follow up right
and then the women didn't follow up you
know they were just like the men you
know so you see they were breaking some
of the boundaries right of bigotry were
you always into these guys and it's just
you're talking about them more now or is
it something that you discovered over
you know over the course of your career
oh no I I discovered them in the course
of this research for unstoppable okay
we're here and let me before we move
into other topics let me ask you because
these are and I'm thinking about this in
terms of like how can Ralph Nader make
the best pitch to a libertarian audience
or you know for things but you you talk
in the book about workfare as clinton ii
or a mischief that and you you you add a
certain point attack people on the left
as well as on the right for saying you
know clinton because liberals did not
look at the hard edges of various kinds
of social welfare programs they allowed
them to get so bad that then they then
they were going to be reformed and
oftentimes the reform was not
particularly useful and you talk about
workfare basically as a stop to
corporate america we can discuss that a
little bit and then you also say that
about other types of things like
you know that people on the Left didn't
attack unions for being really
repressive and suppressive of their own
workers and so you know yeah right so
talk a little bit about you know the the
idea that work fair was not a positive
reform of the welfare system and what
should have happened well basically
because there weren't any jobs and and
the idea of cutting a single mom off
with $300 a month when there were really
no jobs but they couldn't get or she
couldn't get transportation you know -
Oh from the inner city to the suburbs so
what should we do because you know one
of the things that's interesting in the
book is that you're not saying you know
what this you're not saying the status
quo is preferable to what should be but
it's clear that like our social welfare
spending and I would include Social
Security and Medicare in that we have a
system where if you're well-connected
politically and if you're wealthy you
can get a lot of government money and
then it gets harder the less political
power you have
what is a what's a social welfare state
that you would want to see implement
well look at this Milton Friedman
created the minimum incomes plan that
Nixon adopted ran proposed to Congress
and Congress didn't pass it now that is
a reflection of a long tradition of
conservative philosophers for example
Frederick Hayek was opposed to Medicare
and Medicaid because it wasn't universal
he didn't like discriminatory service he
talked about social insurance and these
revered conservative philosophers which
are used by Congress and Paul Ryan and
others and misused they actually
believed in public works they believed
in social insurance they believed in
basically paying a decent wage I mean
Adam Smith would say you know the
workers are the economy how can you not
pay them a decent wait okay well two
things and let's talk about the wages in
a second because you're right about you
know Friedman proposed a plan and it
ended up in a very distorted way
becoming the Earned Income Tax Credit
which does something different but you
know a guaranteed minimum income
essentially or a negative income what
you know would Hayek say well Medicare
is okay because if everybody had it
because it's already
the country it's already bankrupting the
country there's no way to control its
costs or is it that we need a true
social safety net which would not be
based on age it would be based on need
and it would be it would be universally
acceptable but it would be much smaller
than it is now well that's the principle
of Medicare but we know how hard it is
to even get on Medicaid if you're poor
and you don't have children so that
those are those are administrative
details that are very important but the
overall principle is nobody should die
because they can't pay right okay
well let's talk about the wages then
because you you attack Walmart in the
book Walmart you you say at a point in
time quoting Walmart has been the leader
with a low wage policy it as merciless
mercilessly inflicted on its workers and
its domestic producers and talk about
that and what are the effects of okay
there are about a million Walmart
workers who make less today in 1968
adjusted for inflation because the
minimum wage has been stagnant it's now
at seven and a quarter if it was
adjusted for inflation and they would be
making about $10.50
let me photo all right we start with
this Costco starts at eleven fifty an
hour plus benefits how many people does
it employ compared to Walmart well I
mean two probably two three and you got
to pay you got to pay membership fee
just to get into good look that's true
but so it's more expensive but there's a
reason it's not more expensive according
to the CEO of Costco because they have
far less employee turnover they have
more worker productivity and he said
it's the right thing to do I said what
do you mean he said well it stimulates
the economy I mean
consumer demand stimulates the economy
I'm thinking from the consumer point of
yeah there's no question Costco I mean
it has a different set of items for sale
it's more expensive than Walmart you can
go into Walmart and get a shirt and a
meal for a couple bucks you're not you
got a you're gonna pay what 50 60 bucks
just to walk in the door it cost yeah
but you see there's other factors here
Walmart they ski has told its suppliers
in the US can't meet the China price
shut down and go to China will buy your
products and shove them back here
Walmart's CEO makes eleven thousand
dollars an hour eight hours a day and
you know that's crony capitalist
with the Board of Directors you know the
rubber-stamp board of directors yeah
that's not a market oh yeah but here's
here's the rub that it's really
important here in the last six seven
years Walmart has spent 50 1 billion
dollars buying back in stock which
really helps the walton family of course
we've got stock and so on if they had if
they had decided to pay their workers
with that 51 billion which is not a very
productive way to use capital they would
give them a 3050 cents an hour raise for
all their workers right so they put this
is where they prefer to put their money
now where are the investors a Walmart
they don't have any any role in deciding
how so it's a locally traded company
yeah but the investors are powerful here
let me let me I and I don't necessarily
disagree and I disagree that the idea
that investors and it may be that
investors don't do what we would like
them to or that they are fully
disempowered but I you know there's
there's real questions and you know one
of the people that you quote in the book
at several places is David Stockman who
is a friend of reasons and a fascinating
person who does not fit into a
traditional left-right spectrum and
there's more of him speaking up now but
Walmart according to a 2005 study by the
Brennan Justice Center which is not a
right-wing organization or a Walton
foundation you know families they they
said that the average worker at Walmart
was making nineteen thousand dollars a
year which at that time this is 2005 was
more than the average worker at other
discount retailers like Kmart and Target
it was a little bit less than at a UFCW
supermarket if you were in the Union but
overall supermarket workers it was the
same I mean so are they actually paying
their workers less than what the market
bears or are you saying the market is so
rigged that we're getting these people
on the cheap
oh the latter obviously I mean I don't
know where it was Brennan got the data
because we can't get that data or all
they got it from a leaked document in
Walmart you know you know the the
statistical shenanigans when you save
average okay you want to ask yourself
how many people in Walmart are now
making less and
1868 and it's almost a million work but
it's also are they working the same a
number of hours are they no no this
house holds three I'm sorry about full
pay they have a lot of you're right they
have a lot of part-time we're talking
about but I mean but yeah I mean I guess
this is this I think it remains a point
of contention between libertarians and
and your your method of things because
Costco is a great company it's a great
business it's a great business model but
it's one of many Walmart also you know
is a different business model that has
helped keep prices down it's one of the
reasons inflation is flow most
economists would agree so you know but
it's a different model and we don't want
if we want to decentralize power and
decentralize lifestyle we don't want
everybody do but it's classic
concentration of power Walmart they
strip their investors of any kind of
input on this and they go around getting
free land now this is drill yeah
corporates a corporate welfare right
driving out small price lists you know
this book is a lot about Main Street
versus Wall right yeah you know what
yeah yeah yeah and we have like twenty
four areas of left-right convergence
where if we set aside our disagreements
we can finally get something done it's
not like we reach winning yeah yeah the
left and right brackets each winning
because corporatism is a divide rule
very domineering power concentrating
force you know so you know one of the
huge area of convergence I think among
the libertarian right and and a lot of
older line conservatives and many people
on the left and do you define yourself
as a member of the left or the right or
I have to call myself immoral in
Pearce's okay
so I'll take that as a yes but is
defense spending and kind of the
military-industrial complex talk a
little bit about you know why that seems
I mean it's very popular or it's a large
part of the book why did the
military-industrial complex
grow so well to a point where you know
you have somebody like Barack Obama runs
as the peace candidate and immediately
triples troop strengths in Afghanistan
and has not taken a hatchet you know or
even a fingernail clipper yeah the
defense
budget how did the military-industrial
complex just rise to its supremacy well
first of all I exaggerated for in perils
Eisenhower pointed this out and
MacArthur Douglas MacArthur who didn't
agree necessarily I'm much more right
yeah and and it's huge business so if
you can see almost a unwillingness to
resist in Congress so he create these
perils and you exaggerate blood and
there's always some new enemy they're
gonna find the latest is China
you know Iran doesn't quite fit the bill
it's not big enough after the collapse
of the Soviet Union and then you wave
the flag right okay and then you pour
the money campaign money into the
Congress and the White House candidates
and then you show them a map where this
Trident submarine has got sub sub
contracts in and three hundred
congressional districts you don't want
to do that you don't want to close down
your bases right so what who's going to
challenge that this is where there's the
greatest convergence you remember when a
congressman Ron Paul teamed up with
congressman Barney Frank yeah in 2010
that was actually a staffed caucus to
challenge the bloated military budget
but the the the the the industrial war
machine has got their hooks into both
Democrat and Republican parties so how
do you the taboo how do you fix that
because people are talking about this
more than ever I mean Obama you know
very loudly rattled the sabers to go
into Syria and he he got pushed back on
but there's an audience not only though
they were coming in the emails were
coming in like an avalanche and the
members would say to the staff with it
coming in from the Democrats probably
and the staff says both you know and
that terrifies them nothing terrifies
corporatists politicians and corporate
bosses big corporate bonds than a
left-right public opinion going
operational neck right the key is
becoming more visible which is a purpose
book becoming more strategic getting
media getting on the table of candidates
and political agendas are recumbents are
their major party candidates
you find particularly appealing that are
out there now can you name names Walter
Jones Republican from Camp Lejeune land
in North Carolina who he had started out
as a super war Hawk yes the guy who
coined the term freedom fries and now
he's a big he's in actually he's he's
being primary because he's anti-war net
and he won yeah yes yeah that's right no
I mean Walter Jones believes in
constitutional procedures and as Edie
crane told me he said Ralph I oppose
corporate subsidies unconstitutional
Wars the Patriot Act and the Federal
Reserve run amok and I said free that's
pretty good start for convergence right
so he's won I think senator Elizabeth
Warren has kept quiet on militarism in
foreign policy she focuses on financial
industry where she is flat-out terrible
we will we will deliberate why do you
believe that she has any reason to be
against military military might though
if she's kept silent on it why why
should we trust her once she that's an
interesting question I mean she should
be asked that and she basically there's
almost a loyalty oath among Senate and
House Democrats visas of the Obama who
just don't criticize Obama
I mean rosa DeLauro is criticizing him
on a number of issues but there's not
there's not much independent thinking
there how you know we have Obama because
we had bush there is a large argument
out there that we had bush because of
you going back to the 2000 election the
most hopefully the most tightly
contested election of our lifetimes
because it took forever to resolve and
it you know while I didn't vote for
either candidate I didn't vote for you
either in 2000 it didn't turn out the
way I wanted it to I suspect it didn't
for you either in the 2000 election do
you think your presence one of the
arguments that third party candidates
hear all the time is that you cost me
the election if I'm a Republican or a
Democrat did you cost Al Gore the
election no and Al Gore agrees ok no
thanks he thinks he blew it in
Tennessee's on the state everything else
being equal he'd have been in the White
House he got Tennessee and he thinks it
was stolen in a number
ways in Florida so but here's where a
libertarian really supports everybody
has an equal right to run for election
right if everybody has an equal right
then we're either all spoilers of one
another trying to get votes from one
another or none of us as spoilers
we're not second-class citizens because
we're a Green Party candidate or
Libertarian Party candidate I have no
trouble with libertarians on that right
that's all and and the most interesting
thing is I mean the the Brass of these
two parties they control the Election
Commission I think election they
controlled the election machinery so
they keep you off the ballot harass you
file lawsuits delay you exhaust you
you're lucky if you have an eight eight
week post Labor Day campaign to breathe
it yeah and the other thing is they
created this corporation called the
Commission on Presidential Debates the
two parties and they decide who gets on
and who doesn't and after Perot got on
in 1992 the other way was anyone else
going to get on that's why Jimmy Carter
for a number of reasons who's a
monitored a lot of Elections said last
year the u.s. is no longer a functioning
democracy do you agree with that oh I do
well I I don't know if I would put it
quite that way but I agree completely
that no third party candidate has ever
cost anybody a major party candidate an
election because it presumes that all of
our votes rightly belong to the
Democrats or party no and so you know
yes so you do not feel at all
responsible nor should you
let's talk about something that I think
you would want to be partly responsible
for which is your role in airline
deregulation which now when airline
deregulation gets held up it's usually
by Liberal Democrats who say this is a
terrible thing talk a little bit about
why you and Ted Kennedy as well as
Alfred Kahn a democratic I mean an
academic economist at Cornell who is a
Democrat politically as well as people
like Bob pool of Reason Foundation were
all pushing for the deregulation of
airline ticket prices and airports in
the 70 yeah well it was simple it was
not just deregulation of Airlines it was
railroads whose trucking right it was
buses and in many ways trucking gets the
least juice but
it was the most important to to
deregulate interstate trade one of the
most successful yeah but it was what we
call cartel regulation in other words it
regulated markets that regulated entry
of new challenges by blocking them
exactly what the airline's wanted I mean
they created the Civil Aeronautics Board
1937 so in the late 70s we started
getting congressional hearings and we
said look I mean there's no competition
under cartel regulation the fares are
too high the service is lousy routes
aren't being opened up so break it up
get rid of the cartel regulation allow
people's air express to you know fly
from New York to Buffalo for 35 bucks or
whatever and for a while it worked but
you see when I testified against cartel
regulation I had to to reservations one
there had to be strong any trust
enforcement and two there had to be
safety standard well there wasn't strong
antitrust enforcement the department
transportation approved 32 out of 32
airline mergers so now you have fewer
fewer airlines dominating the entire
market but then you had in the cartel
days but by the same token air fares are
cheaper and inflation adjusted terms
direct flights are not as as frequent
but it's also because people live in
different areas so I mean would you know
it had a lot of benefits you make for a
lot of use but you live right so a lot
of benefits koulikov Belize reasserting
it so but what does I mean what bothers
you
other than that there are a few firms
because this is a basic kind of free
market or libertarian approach would be
it doesn't matter how many firms are in
a business as long as there is actual
free entry and no barriers to entry
because even a monopolist has to act as
if they're about to be taken on in a
price war and if if air fares are
cheaper and a fair of service is as good
or better than it was under the cartel
it's still a success even if there are
fewer companies but less and less of a
success and if it wasn't for Southwest
Airlines right it would be but that's a
big but you see here's where the barrier
to
slots in airports so I mean this is part
of the airline deregulation it was also
to deregulate the airports as well right
which are all basically local monopolies
of government authorities so we would be
in for that I would be in for any Pro
Cup competition enforcement yeah here's
an interesting question because you know
as we're talking about competition your
report on the FTC on the Federal Trade
Commission is fascinating reading
because it reads simultaneously very
much like work by the socialist
historian Gabriel Kolko
who from a progressive point of view
said you exactly what you said about the
airline's about the railroad baron said
you know progressives will say we
created you know a regulatory body to
regulate railroad rates and that's a big
success and he was like no the railroads
created that to their advantage and they
froze the market when they were on top
and this is also what James Buchanan and
their public choice economists from a
libertarian angle say the same thing the
regulator's get captured by the people
they're regulating then that was the
essence of your FTC report and RICC
interstate commerce correct Olli is
going right yeah yeah regulatory catch
so talk a little bit about that and then
where where is the sticking point for
you from a kind of full-throated embrace
of a libertarian perspective on
regulatory capture how do you how do you
without unless you get rid of the
regulator's once you always have
regulatory capture no you don't always
have because I mean you you win one here
and one there where you beat the auto
companies for example now the railroads
are under heat because they're carrying
oil and railroad technologies it's not
up to it
I mean air derailment so it's a matter
of public health and safety it's the
most fundamental role of government
Public Health and Safety instead we
spend hundreds of billions I was abroad
blowing up countries and creating more
enemies and knocking our economy instead
of focusing on the public health and
safety I you know I'm not I don't
disagree with you it I know in the book
you talk about
a moment of convergence between people
on the right and the left about war not
not just on defense spending but oversea
Wars and that one of the places where
you got started to argue is like okay if
we're not spending you know 20% of the
budget every year on defense
some people wanted to say okay now we
can spend that on hope
yeah or no we just give it back to
people and that's a real sticking point
I think between things until they lose a
tire in a pothole well here's a question
okay so the Corvair and I have you know
and I want you know the core there which
was a sporty car and it has its you know
it has its fans you know that is the car
that you made infamous and that arguably
you have your you know that was your
entry into really being a huge public
figure that was able to change policy
you argued in unsafe at any speed and
there's no question that cars back then
were unbelievably unsafe compared to the
crappiest car that's put out today but
was the Corvair do you still believe
that the Corvair was less safe than
other cars out there at the time not
less safe than a Volkswagen bug we have
the same handling problem but certainly
less safe than some of the what about I
mean the Ford Falcon and the Plymouth
Valiant the rene renault dauphine was
very unstable too yeah okay because the
nhts in the early 70s released the study
saying the handy handling and stability
performance of the 1962-63 Corvair does
not result in an abnormal potential for
loss of control or rollover and that's
also been found by other people who
looked at the data do you reject that or
do you say that cars you know have just
improved much more because of mandated
safety well they took the worst
comparisons like okay right now dolphine
and so and VW now it was below standards
of even that time of them and the
evidence comes now heavily from inside
General Orders and we rebutted that the
report which was by the way prepared in
part by a former GM consultant it was 20
pages in the and it's true that John
DeLorean who has a checkered history but
he said now I was at GM and there's no
question you knew all about this yeah
and oh the leakage of carbon oxygen is
mutable did they recalled the cars
because of that you can't smell or taste
so here's a question for you you I mean
given without having kind of draconian
government regulation do you think that
cars would be as unsafe now as they were
in 1963 no there's this always an
incremental advance for example Europe
had radial tires and disc brakes mm-hmm
when unsafe in each speed came out the
US manufacturers didn't if there was no
auto safety agency probably because of
the imports right they would have
adopted radial tires how do you how do
you do a lot of other things you know
people would have died in droves year
after year because right I mean look
think they knew about seatbelts in the
1910s their receipt belts in in World
War one planes to keep the pilots you
know falling out but he resisted it to
lure forced to do it in the 1960 here's
a question though because and and this
is you know without a kind of
ideological animus it's a question of
saying okay yeah you know there's no
question that safety belts save lives
any airbags unbalanced save lives and
you know and there's always an adoption
period where there's fluky results but
why isn't it better to inform people of
potential risks and then allowed them to
choose as opposed to say no at this
point going forward
everybody has to shoot at this exact
standard well like how do you how do you
make a cost-benefit analysis of pricing
somebody out of a market because of
safety regulation or something and say
well you know that's there there are
obvious things you know like obvious
safety devices that don't cost much and
reduce your auto insurance premium or
things you can't see like toxic chemical
right or gases you know you can't rely
on people to be scientific detectors of
what their children are exposed to but
you know one thing about all these
conservative philosophers Nick is they
didn't like government coercion but they
didn't like corporate carranza and
corporate coercion now's massive we have
destroyed our freedom of contract with
these fine print contracts they don't
compete between you know American
Express
at visa or for to Jeremiah's I have yet
to see libertarian material on the
destruction of one of the pillars of
freedom in our country which is freedom
of country well I think you know how
it's happened in that nobody reads
contracts online nobody reads the Terms
of agreement or sure you can't read it
but it also in the end it doesn't matter
because I know that I can go from
American Express if they start jerking
me around then I'll go to a visa bank
and if I don't like that visa bank I'll
go to another so there is competition
income but it doesn't matter because the
next person will take me and it's the
same thing with phone contracts and
whatnot where yeah there's no question
that these guys want to ding you yeah
but they have less and less power to
because there is more complication cause
which takes you out from your
constitutional right to go to court okay
which is well big libertarian and well
this is your your biggest thing right I
mean you're against tort reform Tory do
for work yeah okay very good the day in
court trial by jury concrete libertarian
philosophy what was it like you know and
one of the things that you did that is
probably more influential than any of
the actual policy so that you did when
it came out that GM had actually hired
private investigators to follow you
around there were stories about trying
to get you in honeypot situations you
know where you're caught in a
compromising situation how did that make
you feel and how do you think that
changed attitudes towards corporations
in America well it was a frightened at
the time because you didn't know who was
trailing me down Kaneda at a Venetian
loan and saying that I changed at $50
check with 10 fives I mean that's for
the yellows right that's in the
detective
yeah report however fortunately the
press was outraged people were outraged
never mind their political backgrounds I
mean they were trying to discredit
someone who was raising legitimate
issues of Public Safety and unsafe cars
and it helped get the motor vehicle
highway safety browse through in 1966
which have saved a lot oh do you think
the federal government should have
bailed out GM under first under a bush
and then under a
should that of happy that was a tough
one and what was tough about it was
tough about it because if they didn't
who directed a lot of communities a lot
of workers lives so the bailout for me
was for the workers and the communities
and the suppliers the auto suppliers but
wouldn't it have its better yeah this is
a company that if it wasn't saved by
Uncle Sam would have closed down right I
mean you're not talking about well close
the factory here right but wouldn't it
have been better off I mean in the long
run and it's one thing to say okay
people a lot of people in one's vibrant
less now less vibrant industry lose
their jobs and that that's gone yeah and
then we help them until they can get on
their feet as opposed to saving a
company which we know you know is now
back you know they they managed to name
their first woman's CEO just in order to
have her testify about faulty ignition
switches in front of Congress I mean why
are we propping up a company which has
again and again earned the public you
know kind of higher yeah well normally I
couldn't agree more but they had
hundreds of thousands of workers but
what those workers would go elsewhere I
mean they would be picked up by other
companies and then the people well but
then are we stuck then where we have to
we will you know if we live to be
another hundred years old we will be
still talking about the next GM ALM
knows we can because because what
brought down GM especially was their
finance arm they shouldn't have been in
that business they started playing
around with derivatives like gee should
they be receive a GM see back in the 60s
when GM had like 65 percent right
protection yeah I mean because imports
couldn't the Antitrust Division actually
had an indictment ready to break him up
under the in Iran had they broken him up
into five companies you would not have
had this problem with the GM bailout by
the same token the the finance arm was
the only arm that was making money for
well that was part of jazz mismanagement
yeah I mean it's bad management but
yours as well should it be absolutely
but should it be the role of people that
are a you know I don't drive a GM car
and I don't own stock and G why should I
be involved
in their governance shouldn't that be up
to the stockholders and the people who
are foolish enough to buy a GM car
obviously if they bailed out in return
the US government owns 62 percent of GM
and what they should have done with that
ownership was restructure the company so
it never happens again yeah that's the
problem I think the only way it's never
gonna happen again as if they let it die
but again a point of disagreement but
there's a lot of convergence here and I
now I want to talk about the most
shameful probably the most shameful
episode in your career which is in
November 1970 one reason we published a
story of yours called you can fight City
Hall which had originally been published
in the Fremen a great Liberty it's the
oldest kind of continuously published
libertarian magazine in the country and
this was about a public housing project
in your hometown of Winsted Connecticut
which was going to be passed and then
individuals in the community rose up to
put it down what was that story and you
know talk a little bit about that and
you know what is interesting here is
that you are in favor of mass movement
of mass mobilization and against experts
telling people how to live their lives
well that's a long discussion you know
in this particular case there were empty
apartments reasonably priced owned by
private real estate people so what why
and who were willing to rent yeah I mean
so it wasn't even like they had some
reason they weren't no they were empty
and and so the argument was why should
local taxpayers who pay federal taxes
set up public housing units when you
have available housing in the area I
mean the whole principle of public
housing and one reason by the way
Senator Robert Taft supported public
house end of his 50s mr. conservative
right was when there was no housing
mmm-hmm and that wasn't the case in this
town so I spoke out against do you you
bring up an interesting question and
it's a huge threat and unstoppable about
how you know that the kind of modal
right-winger is now very different than
what you know that Robert Taft if Robert
Taft wouldn't have recognized you know
Newt Gingrich as a conservative
something has changed or Paul
Brian as a conservative do you think
there has been a similar shift on the
left so that we're in the Democratic
Party where I don't know who would be a
archetypal Democrat Jose John F Kennedy
would he recognize Barack Obama as being
in the same party or it has has the you
know modal Democrat moved as far out as
you would argue the typical conservative
no actually they've been very consistent
mm-hmm and not bold enough I mean does
the total support of the
military-industrial complex an empire
and war by Barack Obama Hillary Clinton
is staggering I mean it would stagger
Eisenhower it would even blush Nixon
yeah I you know Reagan you know when he
called the evil empire the Soviet Union
which you would agree with you're a
critic of the Soviet Union you're not a
you're not a commie yeah okay and when
he saw hunt 200,000 people marching for
nuclear arms-control and he saw
well-dressed Republicans hung them he
turns around and he breaks ground with
Gorbachev so and it was Nixon who went
to China you know I was Kissinger you
know everybody
some of us wish he had never come back
and and they were they don't get freaked
out by challenges from the right like
Buchanan the Democrats go nuts from
challenges from the left I mean we were
sued 24 times in 12 weeks
in the summer of 2004 to get us off one
state ballot after another no and it
didn't well it kind of worked right you
had a bunch of weaker cowing in 2000 it
totally exhausted us one time we got a
notice to be in pencil nine pennsylvania
state courts on monday warned run here
is a speaking of criticism from the left
you know it it you know people on the
left identify heavily with you and so
they have the most criticisms because we
always hate our twin brother or you know
sibling more than somebody on the other
side this quote of yours from the
Washington Post in 1984 gets a lot of
play on the left
I don't think there is a role for unions
in small nonprofit cause organizations
any more of them within a monastery
monastery from the Washington Post do
you stand by that and how what is your
general attitude towards unions unions
are needed these are the large companies
who can basically abandon our country
close them down go to fascists and
communist regimes and set up where they
put their workers at baby cents an hour
in their place but your your yeah
nonprofit there's first of all nobody's
making money I mean you don't have a guy
making $10,000 an hour and second it's a
completely different mission it's a it's
a charitable mission and educational
mission and it's overwhelmingly white
collar you don't have dungeon factories
you don't have thats bestest you don't
have chemicals glad that we didn't show
you the the first floor the reason
offices where we're doing all of that
but what about in the public sector
because you know Franklin Roosevelt was
against public sector unions a lot of
people were should there be public
sector unions well I think so for things
like social services like there's still
even though there are unions in the
federal government there's no maternity
leave paid maternity leave you know they
give you three months a mother delivers
a child three months unpaid maternity
leave and then they have a daycare
center at the department education for
15,000 bucks a year probably contracted
out I agree you know heck and these
conservative lobs
I really believe there should be a
safety net right and life is too short
to spend every living minute trying to
figure out how to make the most basic
necessities payable right you know
here's the difference probably between
libertarians in Maine and that is I
believe people should get a living wage
they should have the right to associate
through collective bargaining because
that's what investors do through
corporations and they should get a
return on their taxes the taxes should
not go to football stadiums it should
not go to you know the 12th aircraft
carrier that we don't need it should go
back to the
and good that people can't do for
themselves like public transit do say
like a sewage and water systems it's
simple like that and it's amazing and
why I put so much in this book on the
conservative philosophers is they got
that they got that in the 18th century
the 19th century the 20th century but
you don't see that among so-called
conservative politicians in Congress
because they're not conservative they're
corporatists I've never met a
conservative who calls himself
corporatist I've been a lot of corporate
to sign papal Hill who call themselves
conservative the Left business observer
run by Doug Henwood who's a smart guy on
the left he finds a lot to like in your
light certainly in your life and in your
politics and everything but when I'm
running for president that's right well
this is everybody on the Left because
the nation every every four years they
dust off that old letter saying Ralph we
agree with you on everything which is
why you should never run for president
yeah but he talked about your brand of
humorless hair shirt politics that
there's a lot of pain and not a lot of
laughter or a lot of you know I mean a
lot of humor or a lot of irony in your
politics
is that a fair you know is that a fair
estimation of what you're about of
course that five times on Saturday night
well I came in third to Grover Norquist
in a humor contest a few months ago in
humor there's truth yeah humor is really
a great lubricant and hard times and you
know some of the people who suffer the
most in the world have the best humor
and does that include being Lebanese in
Connecticut talk a little bit about what
it was like growing up in the in the 30s
and 40s in you know old New England yeah
as a Lebanese it's surprisingly Placid
my parents never made it many a big deal
out of ethnicity or ethnic politics well
they didn't have to though right because
that's what the mainstream society was
doing well it was a very mixed ethnic
community yeah I mean obviously you you
get it you hear a slur once in a while
camel driver or something like that but
it wasn't very serious what you know how
does that factor into your views on
immigration
do you think that should we have open
borders I mean you don't believe in open
borders for goods and services do you
believe in open borders for people no I
don't believe in corporate managed trade
agreements okay III don't particularly
like barriers between countries but we
have to control our borders because we
oppress people in Central America we
side with the oligarchies and the status
in these areas or dictators so so these
people are so desperate they head north
I mean why don't we have a more benign
foreign policy where these countries can
look anomic lead develop I don't
disagree with that but I mean if we're
siding with oligarchs isn't the least we
can do is let them come here and have a
better quality of life yeah but then you
have to ask how it drives down wages in
this country okay and you you believe
that it definitely that immigration in
general and illegal immigration which
tends to be more have a higher
percentage of low skilled people drives
down wages no of course surplus labor
it's called you know rather cruelly in
economic literature the wall street
journal' decide no actually I don't
think the wall street or if the wall
street journal' does there are plenty of
reasons to believe that that's not the
case that illegal immigrants tend to
complement existing areas my objections
h-1b visa where we import scientists
engineers doctors nurses when we can
develop our own and there's plenty of
surplus technical people in this country
so you Farrakhan Valley once these
people come in from the third world
because they're more pliable do you
think it's because they're more pliable
and it's not because they're desperate
for as many people they can get their
hands on I think integrating I think
they're more pliable but it's a brain
drain we tell a third world use your
human resources develop your country
grow your markets and we suck out of
them
the entrepreneurs the scientists a civil
engineers the physicians for our benefit
we're hogs in that way I'm sorry too
yeah no I was gonna I'm glad that
America before my all four of my
grandparents came over and it's like
they wouldn't have been able to come
over now and I I don't consider I you
know Ireland and Italy deserve the brain
drain they had on them I suspect Lebanon
did too well but you don't have to have
actual incentives it doesn't mean you
don't come in but to have an affirmative
magnet to know deep deep populate these
areas of they're skilled doers the
people who are gonna transform the
political economy is short-sighted well
I do agree that I like the fact that
you're consistent because this is one of
the things that I think drives a lot of
libertarians nuts as conservatives will
say yes to goods and services coming
across the border but no to people and
you you know what one libertarians have
a but you know a bug up their butts
about consistency so good interesting
libertarians have criticized NAFTA in
the world yeah certainly people like Ron
Paul does quite a bit as managed trade
the question is is it better than what
exists before and I think I would
certainly argue that we NAFTA is better
than no NAFTA but let me to do more
research I do I do to two final
questions one is you know I
Nader's Raiders I mean you did not just
when you were young younger when you
were starting out you didn't just create
you didn't just write books you created
a movement that you know is still felt I
mean the the people in various you know
think tanks and government agencies and
journalistic outlets all have some route
in an organization that you started or
directly to send from you what was it
about the zeitgeist in the late 60s that
you know that allowed things things to
happen and do you feel like we're in
that moment again where anything is
possible or where radical change for the
good can happen that's a really
interesting question first of all I
decided early in the 1960s on became
very well known I wasn't going to be a
lone ranger I was gonna build I define
leadership as you know producing more
leaders and not followers right okay so
and that's the way you produce a
movement the zeitgeist was really
interesting people's routines at a young
age were disrupted by the civil rights
struggle the women's struggle the
Vietnam War the environmental crisis and
that produced a lot of young people who
saw as their life's work trying to
better society
and and you don't see that now because
they're not part of any risk they don't
have to go to Iraq or Afghanistan on a
college campuses
and they don't see their jobs going
although their jobs are going because
they're not blue-collar workers and so
you don't get that kind of committed
leadership I mean out of there but
you're saying that in the you know over
the past 20 years with the rise of
networked computers and the rise of kind
of instantaneous communication and and
radical shifts in the way people live
their daily lives
you don't see that as disruptive in a
positive way well it is in terms of
invading people's privacy and generating
huge outlets for gossip
I mean I've just told there is a Pew
poll where the 13 to 16 year olds in
this country average 11,500 text
messages a year each okay so in that
sense well I haven't read them yes but I
think it's it's shredding their brains I
I just think this massive dedication of
time looking at screens and we're now in
a screa
yeah here in the hand everywhere you
know TV and you don't have you don't
have a cell phone no do you use a
computer no never touch it I use it
Underwood typewriter when the lightning
strikes and knocks out the electricity
I'm still working so how are you in a
position to now have this stuff I mean
clearly clearly the internet helped your
candidacy in 2000 to raise money yeah
not to get votes no no but I'm saying
there aren't those two things connected
so I mean but you're you're saying that
what the the shift in the zeitgeist in
the 60s it was because people's lives
young people's lives were being
disrupted with the threat of violence
either being killed or if you are a
woman not having equal rights or a
minority and that the disruption now is
not moving towards a positive social end
no basically is anesthesia it's
addiction its Internet addiction so this
is like brave new world the Internet is
soma the drug that people drink and
break we're beyond the brave in the
world except for soma that's the NSA
it's a very serious problem we have to
read
examine what this technology is doing to
us over all ages and what it is it's
it's not getting people to show up half
a democracy showing up marches
demonstrations City Council meetings
going to vote and people are not doing
that they're watching screens which and
I would be a mess remiss if I didn't ask
about this you a couple years ago you
referred to games and gamers as
electronic child molesters your
companies stand by that the companies
are seducing the young at their weakest
point where you have two three million
people of young age immediately playing
a new video game you wouldn't have in
that community let's let's slow it
around the cat that's fine but you know
it's a proportion do you really want to
be addicted to this I mean some parents
tell me these games take ten hours a day
of some of these kids if you've let them
yeah I mean but it could be something
else right but well I guess as a final
question then here's what I draw all
right Nick virtual reality is okay you
know watching internet but where things
really happen is reality and if the
young generation spending more and more
time in virtual reality watching screens
and the quality of what they're watching
right they're not going to inherit the
civic engagement and responsibilities of
their elders so as a final question and
I would I would actually disagree that
those two things are in parallel as
opposed to they intersect virtual
reality online communication in the real
world are intersecting but except in the
allocation of time well here's I mean so
are you optimistic we've seen vast
changes yeah those past 50 years in
American society you've been a huge part
of that without exaggeration do you
think that the potential in 50 years
from that will be will have moved as far
forward as we did in the past 50 years
or well are we going into darkness
contrary you a lot of opinion I think
science and technology is being used by
concentrated power to close out
deliberative democracy to close out
thinking for oneself to increase
conformity under the guise of
liberated text messaging and when you go
into genetic engineering controlled by
Monsanto and others the seeds the floor
of the fauna you go into nanotechnology
these are hugely transformed with
technologies that are not under a frame
of democratic processes so I I always am
optimistic because I like it as a
strategy when I was at Princeton I
studied the Philosopher's of pessimism
like Schopenhauer
I was not convinced and I see pessimism
as a self-indulgence and a cop-out all
right well we will leave it there with
Ralph Nader whose latest book is
unstoppable the emerging left-right
alliance to dismantle the corporate
state Ralph I'll look forward to the
next book thank you or say thanks Nick